alhamdulillah
[Silence]
m
for
[Silence]
m
wasallam
[Silence]
We are continuing in our
book we mention this every week but just
so
people don't think that the class
changed or anything We've mentioned
before Z is a very dense very
lengthy
book and it's usually printed in its
original form in five up to 10 volumes
it's a very lengthy
book
however we are not obviously reading
every word of every page
in that we wouldn't finish for 10 years
if we did that 20 years as the way we're
going
and it wouldn't be appropriate for us to
read everything in because there's a lot
of debate and discussion and issues that
have to do with the science of Hadith
and issues that have to do with and the
different and so forth which he
discusses rather what the book
originally is about is everything having
to do with the prophet Muhammad S.I
wasallam especially
with an emphasis on that which
is of consequence to his
followers that which is of consequence
to his followers so basically it's a
book on S it's a biographical
book
which derives lessons and meanings
from which is is very
important to the point that he doesn't
even mention all of the usually when you
read in books of s if you read even
smaller books
by
a when you read the sealed nectar which
is a very good book very clean and very
eloquently
written and it is extremely popular and
rightfully so we see that usually they
begin with mentioning the time that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam lived
lived in what what era what were the
people doing at that time what were
their beliefs right also mentioning
certain Wars that took place and the
politics between the different tribes
who were the Kings what was the state
the political state of the Arabs the
social the economic Etc so that you know
and also what we know of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam life and
times before he was a prophet before he
was a messenger these are important
things to know but they are not of great
consequence to us in our daily lives
what is of great consequence to the
individual follower of Muhammad and
devote are the things which he taught us
as a prophet as a messenger and intended
for us to follow and implement this is
what is mainly of consequence for us and
so he focused on that so even from a
perspective a historian's perspective if
you look at there's a lot of things
missing that would be found in other
books dedicated to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam biography
however he is merely mentioning what is
of greatest consequence to every Muslim
that every Muslim should know about the
prophet sallallah alai wasam so we
obviously mention what is of consequence
and these other things which are more
specific to books of Hadith books of
transmitters of Hadith and so forth we
left out but then there were also some
things that were not mentioned in
detail such
as many of the physical traits of the
Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam many
of the aspects of his character they
were mentioned but more mentioned as not
just how his character was but how he
has commanded us to conduct ourselves
likewise the Miracles of the Prophet
sallallah Ali wasallam which is where we
have arrived at now we definitely have
to be acquainted with his
miracles and the one that is living
still amongst us is the book of Allah
the Quran this is the Eternal and
most most significant miracle and
gift that Allah subhanahu waala has
given any human being and Any Nation for
this reason the Quran
it has in it everything relevant of all
of the previous books how many book
books were there at least
315 at least we know of five or six
right we know of the Quran the in
the that was given
to we know
the of ibraim and some Scholars at a six
then they distinguish
between the of mus and the T So mus was
given two or was he given one difference
of
opinion but that is only the most
important of those books every messenger
now we we mentioned in detail before
previous classes the difference between
a prophet and a messenger we said that
difference can be summarized in the in
the rule that every messenger is a
prophet but not every Prophet is
necessarily a messenger in the narration
of
ab which is
ined that the prophet s wasam was asked
how many Messengers were
sent and he said
315 he was then asked and Prophets he
said
123,000 every me messenger has a
book and the most important difference
between a messenger and a prophet is
that a messenger is sent to a people who
are not Muslim they are they are
disbelievers they worship idols or they
worship other than Allah subhanahu wa
taala a messenger is sent to a people
that are
fundamentally at odds with the religion
of Allah subhanahu wa taala the
fundamentals the Oneness of Allah the
nature and disposition of the human
being Etc and so every messenger has a
book Allah subhanahu wa tells
us he says indeed we have sent our
Messengers bearing Miracles and we sent
down with
them the books and the scales scales
meaning proper
reasoning and the way to distinguish
between right and wrong and to weigh
things and so every messenger has a book
The the most important of those books
are the five that we are told of in the
Quran and all relevant meanings in those
books are found in the Quran all of them
so the Quran is
really a recap a summary of all that
Allah subhanahu waala has told
Humanity so this is the greatest Miracle
but there are many other
Miracles that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
sent with M with Muhammad s. wasam to
the point that the scholars mention that
any Miracle given given to a prophet or
messenger
prior it's equivalent
or better is given to the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
s you can see that pattern very
clearly was able to speak to the dead
meaning those who were once alive he
could speak to them
again and the prophet sallallah wasam
was able to speak to inanimate objects
things that were never alive in that way
trees and stones and even food and we
mention that when the Jewish of K tried
to poison him it was the food itself
that spoke to him and informed him of
the poison in
it
so these are this is of course a very
condensed
summarized
summarized class with regards to the
main most prominent miracles of the
Prophet s.
wasam but they are in the
thousands and add to that anything that
happens of miraculous
nature for the followers of the Prophet
Muhammad s. wasam those things are as
well considered to be of his
miracles right they are considered to be
an extension of the Miracles he was was
[Silence]
given
and
[Silence]
for
another we reached last week to our
in our discussion regarding some of the
prophecies that the prophet s. wasam was
given these prophecies span from things
that happened in the
past ancient history or recent history
which
was debated amongst the people of the
book or and setting things straight as
well as things that are happening in
real time and things that were to
happen sometimes decades sometimes
centuries sometimes
Millennia after the prophet
alam's
death one of those things was the
death of he was in
Yemen and he claimed to be a messenger a
prophet he had a large army put
together he was maming and killing
Muslims and
others and the night in which he was
killed and his foot FNA put to rest the
prophet sallallah Ali wasallam informed
the companions that night
exactly when he had
died he
says he then
mentions a prophecy regarding
the
Mongols the the mongr were a people that
came from Asia they came into the Muslim
world it's not just Muslims that they
killed but they kind of specialized in
that due to a a poor decision made by
the Khalifa of the Muslim in Bagdad at
that time he offended Genghis Khan and
when that happened he set out to
conquer and he set out to punish so he
had it really had it out for the Muslims
and there were great battles that took
place between the Muslim armies and
the Tatar and these wars continued on
and raged on for decades until finally
they accepted
Islam it was said at that time their fno
was so terrible that it was
said you know it was kind of a common
saying that if someone tells you that
they lost a battle do not believe them
that's something unbelievable it was
unimaginable that they could lose a
battle at that time this is how
terrified people
were and they did defeat many of the
Muslim armies But ultimately Islam
defeated them meaning that they accepted
Islam they became Muslim and
Islam spread into those
parts largely because of those
battles the prophet Sall alai wasallam
tells us that one of the things that
would happen in the future he tells his
companions is that they would
fight
[Silence]
as
for
[Silence]
said
r
[Silence]
ad
said
[Silence]
and Allah
subhah
[Silence]
for
another thing that he mentioned was
he prophesized the battles that would
rage on between the Tartar and the
Muslims the great Muslim armies at the
time and this Waring between these
two civil ations continued on for many
many years and finally Allah subhanahu
waala placed Islam into the hearts of
many of them and they accepted
Islam and their leaders and the
grandchildren of gangas
Khan accepted
Islam these
tartar
they
they the scholars of that
time and most of the scholars up until
today have agreed that yet and the
beginning of their immersion was with
the with the
Tatar person may say well how does that
work
we know
inah that Allah subhanahu waala tells us
the story
of and
that when he reached a place far in the
north according to the majority of the
scholars of
T He Came Upon A people who were being
terrorized by Y and Ma yet that and me
are two tribes of human
beings anytime you read
stories about Y
and that articulate that they are not
human there's stories that and they all
Clash too there are stories about Y and
ma that some of them are so tiny they
will be able to go in a shoe and think
that it is a palace right right and then
other narrations not narrations of the
Prophet sallallah alaihi wasallam
accounts things that are mentioned by
the people of the book and that some of
them are one hand span tall and some of
them are two hands span tall and some of
them are three hands span tall then you
have clashing with those
narrations or you know accounts
that are very very tall and they have
teeth that are fangs that are coming
out different monsters and they
have tongues that are drills that they
drill walls with and so forth all of
these accounts are inaccurate incorrect
all of these accounts are not from the
prophet sallallah
wasam what is from the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is that he
tells us that on the day of judgment
Allah subhanahu waala will summon Adam
and he will say separate now from your
Offspring those who are destined for
hell and so he will ask and who are they
he will say out of every
1,999 and at that point people will be
swept in a wave of Black Terror the
prophet s. wasam saw that the compan
ions were very terrified and a bit
disheartened by
this what's the chances of you or I
being that one out of N Out of a
thousand but the prophet sallallah wasam
then told them do not fret for out of
every for every one of you there is 999
of Y and
Ma now if we understand this narration
we understand two things number one we
understand that Y and Ma these are names
of tribes they're not names of a species
of animals or Monsters they are The
Offspring of Adam Adam only had what
only had human beings as his
offspring some books books of history
books that have been authored and
unfortunately
translated articulate and have accounts
that Adam was said to have fallen asleep
and he had a discharge or a wet dream
while he was sleeping that went seeped
into the ground and from it came Y and
all kinds of very at landish things none
of these are authentic none of these
things are from the prophet sallallah
alai wasam there's nothing there's
nothing
absolutely authentic and clear with
regards
to the tribes of Y and Ma being
anything but human they're human
beings and another thing that we
understand from this narration for every
one of you when he said to the
companions you he's speaking about the
Muslims for every one of you there are
999 of Y and
Ma if that you know if we thought about
it that yes there's a wall
and we imagine you know the Muslims how
many billions and billions of
Muslims have been on the
earth we would see that by this time
there would be so many billions or even
trillions of Y and ma that they could
climb out on top of each other over the
wall at this
point but this is not the case in the
time of he built the wall to keep their
evil to them and to protect the rest of
the
people to the south of them but over
the years centuries past and so forth
they had children and they migrated to
different lands and they spread
throughout the whole
world so when he Sall alai wasallam says
out of for every one of you there are
900 199 of Y and Ma this is speaking
about all of the people of the Hellfire
after the prophet sallallahu alai
wasallam
sending and so for this
reason the wall of Y and Ma
remains however are there trillions of
people behind that
wall no these these tribes of Y and Ma
have
spread and they have have filled the
Earth to the Far East to the Far
West to the north to the
South and that
wall
as mentions in his
book he says that that
wall REM remains as an indicator
for the time when the hour will strike
because Allah subhah wa taala tells us
that when the hour
[Silence]
comes the prophet Allah subhanahu waala
tells us that near the end of time that
wall will be reduced to
rubble and when that occurs what will
happen that is when the people of that
time will turn against and these great
Wars will happen will turn against the
people of Islam and these great Wars
will
happen and that will
facilitate of course before that Isa
will return to the Earth and so forth so
that wall doesn't necessarily have to be
keeping them back now that's wall
remains as what remains as an indicator
for the
time when those prophecies will come to
pass and for this reason we see that all
the way back in the time of the Prophet
sallallah alai
wasallam a hole had eroded itself into
that wall the narration
of
[Silence]
for
the prophet Sall wasallam tells us that
one day he awoke Z tells us that he
awoke he was very clearly terrified his
face was very red his his voice was
high and he said woe to the Arabs in
Arabs here what's meant by it is the
Muslim in general woe to
them and
very impending
doom the impending doom of the hour and
the release of Y and Ma he says
today a hole was born into the wall of Y
and
Ma of this size and he made a circle
between his his
finger and his his thumb and his index
finger that happened all the way back
then it's not going to get smaller from
that
time it will get wider that wall remains
as an indicator
for the End of Time the impending doom
of the release and the
complete coalition
between the enemies of Islam and the
Muslim together so it will be
two so the narrations which are ascribed
to the prophet
s or some of the companions have said
and so forth that Y and Ma they have
these very strange traits some of them
are super short some of them are super
tall some of them have huge elephant
ears some narrations have ears the
ears of elephants when they want to go
to sleep they lay on one as a as a as a
mattress and they cover up with the
other ear these things are not
authentic they're not of the words of
the prophet
sallallah and often times
history you know how if you study
this over time if we were able to put
those stories on a timeline
the further back we
go right the more those stories will
change and become more
reasonable why because the state of any
thing that is passed down orally and is
not passed down
religiously is going to be distorted as
it goes it's kind of if you play
the game telephone when you are kids
we have one person and we have 10 15
people you whisper something to the
person behind you and by the time it
reaches the 15th person it's a
completely different statement at that
time right so these distortions will
increase over
time and being that these things are
taken from the Christians and the Jews
mainly but elsewhere as well
from the people of that time who were
very superstitious were very
inaccurate in their descriptions very
weak in their knowledge and the
disciplines of their sciences and
perfecting their religion these stories
come out and so if you read in books
if you read in books like
book of History authored by a a book
of History authored by IB cath which has
less in it but nonetheless has
has a very well-known book of
the the book
of you'll find that he mentions these
statements and these narrations in these
accounts it's not because he believes it
it's not because it's valid but the
science of History you mention
everything that comes to the historian
mentions everything that he has
gathered as for what is correct what is
incorrect what is a weak standing what
is strong and authentic this is a
separate science in The Sciences of
Islam and so sometimes people are you
see in our modern day we have things
Google Earth and we have satellites
and we have and we have looked through
you know
every most of the earth if not all of it
there will always remain some of it
undiscovered but most of it and we have
not seen these trillions of people that
that live behind this wall so people
start coming up with different ways to
understand
this say are actually
underground right they got the wall
there and they're actually living
underground in a hollow Earth well this
causes more problems than it does give
us a
solution because all of these human
beings for thousands of years living
underground by this time their vision
would
become pretty much non-existent their
skin will not be able to handle any UV
rays when they come out from underground
they're going to be all but useless on
on top of the earth they're right
they'll be wiped out by the common cold
so this is we have no evidence for these
things are here on the earth with us and
the prophet Sall
Alam Allah subhah waala before him in
the Quran he
prophesized them
collaborating
and slaying and killing everyone that
opposes them everyone that they come
around come
across Allah subhanahu waala said
sometimes people they become nervous
about these things you know I know
that Allah said this in the Quran I know
that there are narrations about this but
I can't understand how that
is the first thing we do when we can't
understand something is we
say I believe in
it whatever it is I believe in it I
don't have to know exactly how it is in
order for me to believe in
it and second of all we make sure that
we don't come into
outlandish explanations to try to
explain these things
away sometimes people will say things
well you know where would Y and Ma
be because we haven't seen them on our
satellites therefore yeah J J is just
metaphorical it's not actually people
it's just metaphorical it's a metaphor
for different diseases or different
you know crises that will emerge Against
Humanity at the time and so forth this
is this is incorrect all of the Muslims
agree that Y and Ma are real physical
people that will collaborate against the
people of the Earth at that
time likewise people make the same
kind of mistake with regards to a for
instance the return
of that a is not actually a human being
he's not actually a person it's a
metaphor for a certain state of mind
that will spread and so forth that is
inaccurate that's incorrect that causes
more trouble why because we have clear
authentic agreed upon narrations of the
Prophet
sallam describing to us in
detail what this person looks
his eye is in such and such way the
other eye looks like
this he has very curly hair right he has
a very strong physique to the point that
he's almost he's almost hunched over
from the the density of his
muscles right that he does this and he
this is descriptions of a human being
he's a human
being we have to be able to trust our
Scholars I think one of the worst the
worst pieces of
propaganda that has ever Afflicted the
Muslims in history
is it's having bad thoughts and
harboring insecurities and doubts and
reservations about the scholars of Islam
Allah subhanahu waala created these
people he created these human beings to
protect our minds and to protect our
hearts and our religion this is how
Allah he promised to save this religion
preserve it that is how he has preserved
it subhanahu
waala and when our Scholars tell us
something and they agree upon it we need
to accept doesn't mean that we'll
understand everything we may
not but going to explanations like
this and
well these are just metaphors a person
could say that about Adam and how there
is just a metaphor there wasn't actually
a person named Adam there wasn't
actually a woman named Ha and some
Muslims have tried to do that why
because they drank from Darwin's
Kool-Aid so now they have to somehow
explain that how can you how can you say
we evolved from
fish but at the same time Adam was
created Allah created him with his
two hands and that Allah placed Spirit
into how do you how do you put those two
together you have to say that one is
literal and the other is not that is for
the scholars of Islam to decide and we
follow
them that is enough for tonight
in
abbb